I got to be careful the way I say this.
>> If BB Netanyahu, if he does something I
don't like, and if I criticize it, am I
like a bad Christian?
>> Absolutely not. What I find strange is
that we're able to criticize the
American government sometimes in the
Christian world with more freedom than
the Israeli government.
>> Now, Charlie Kirk rejected an offer
earlier this year from Israel's Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu. Just
imagine, guys, this is their way of
negotiating. What does the mafia, the
gang, Israel do? Listen, critic
publicly, privately, you don't have to
do this. We will fund you. You're a good
guy. Come back. No, no, no. Not working.
Okay, no problem.
Everything you own, from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters, and donate towards this
message, inshallah, a new project that's
only $500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama. And
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go, but your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Brothers and sisters, subhan Allah, I
have been looking and digging deeper and
doing some research and I want to give a
shout out. Uh, I don't know who they
are, but this where I got my information
from as well. A brilliant video from
Propaganda and Co. They're on X. You can
follow them. This is where the video is.
I'm going to put an article as well to
this. It gets crazy and crazier, guys.
This makes sense. What I'm about to show
you guys, you have to listen carefully
because we've got a whole timeline and
I'm going to play the videos of this
propaganda and co as well. Why Benjamin
Netanyahu left the war room and is
adamantly trying to put in KV in our
memories that Charlie Kirk was
pro-Israeli when he was not and he was
getting bullied. And we've got more
evidence by those Zionist funders that
he even feared for his life. Listen to
this clip. We're going to start with
this and this is going to get wild. It
is going to get wild.
>> If BB Netanyahu if he does something I
don't like and if I criticize it, am I
like a bad Christian?
>> Absolutely not. What I find strange is
that we're able to criticize the
American government sometimes in the
Christian world with more freedom than
the Israeli government. To be pro-Israel
means you believe in the nation of
Israel, not necessarily the government
of Israel. When when Joe Biden was
president, you and I were we loved
America, but we detested our government.
And those two those two things
beautifully coexisted.
>> Yeah. You never you never once said,
"Hey, I'm I'm out on America." Exactly.
>> And what they don't want is they don't
want to be called bad Christians. If
they challenge a foreign government,
which is what happens so often, like
you're a bad Christian if you have a
question about a foreign government,
that creates backlash that I don't think
people understand.
>> Good. So, firstly, we understand,
brothers and sisters, you can clearly
see this is a Charlie Kirk. This is this
is the new evolution of Charlie Kirk.
This is not him before. So, do you see
why they were so adamantly trying to
imprint in our minds that Charlie Kirk
blow was speaking out against them. Now,
this is from Candace Owens. Charlie Kirk
was fighting with some very powerful
billionaires that he took money from
over things over things he was
discussing. The pressure on him was
immense over the last two weeks. The
truth will be revealed. The message will
be leaked and the movement he built will
rise up. K's doing a fantastic job. Who
are the two journalists? Max Blumenthal
and Anna Parampill are the ones who came
out with this are the ones who came and
start to talk about how Charlie Kirk was
slowly but surely changing his mind.
Why? Because brothers and sisters this
is what he had to say. So we can see on
the screen we're going to do like a
little uh thing here power
pronunciation. Charlie Kirk refused
Netanyahu funding offer. Benjamin
Netanyahu offered him a direct funding
which going to read in a minute as well
inshallah and he refused it. He refused.
He was frightened by pro-Israel forces
before death. Friend reveals
friend reveals that he was frightened,
guys. He was frightened. Subhan Allah.
Yes. Okay. And who are these? His
critics. His critics had an issue
because he invited Megan uh Tucker
Carlson and um I think his name is David
of course and the comedian as you can
see on the screen. Why on his platform?
He had the power to do this. He invited
them and they were pissed off with him.
was so angry with him why he did that. A
Trump insider and longtime friend of
Charlie Kirk tells the uh Greyzone how
the assass how the assassinated
conservative lead leaders turning point
on Israel influence provoked a private
backlash from Netanyahu's allies that
left him angry and afraid. So this is
what they're talking about. They are not
leaving this in the people's minds. And
the question everybody asks, why not
Candace Owens? Why not Carson? Why not
Megan? Why not these individuals? But
Charlie Kirk, there's a reason be behind
this. There's a reason behind this
inshallah. So in Latin the words kubono
which means who benefits and this word
and like I said in the video that you
watch will tell you to find a criminal
you need to understand who benefits from
his killing. Who benefits from his
killing? Does Americans benefit from it?
No. There's like a civil war about to
happen. They didn't benefit at all. Who
benefited? Did Iran benefit from it? No.
He went to the Trump uh office and had
an had a a a nearly a verbal uh debate
with Trump about not to attack Iran. So
no, who who benefited from this? Does
Katar benefit from this? Did Gaza
benefit from this? No. There you go.
Let's let's carry on. Let's carry on
with So here is uh the letter of Okay.
Kirk was an was 18 years old when he
launched the
True USA in 2012 uh from it. um
inception. His career was propelled by
Zionist donors who showered his young
organization with money through neo-
conser conservative outfits like David
uh David Huro Horowits Freedom Center.
Yeah, bloody these people are horror. He
repaid his wealthy um backers over the
years by unleashing a relentless fire ho
fire hose of anti-Palestinian and
Islamophobic
um diet tribes accepting uh sorry
accepting propaganda trips to Israel and
sternly shutting down nationalist force
uh forces challenging his support for
Israel during the true USA events. In
the Trump era, few America uh American
Gentiles had proved more valuable to
self-proclaimed Jewish state than
Charlie Kirk. Yep. So bear that in mind.
Now,
yes, not only that, he was even
following this girl called Syrian uh
Syrian girl on X and this is what she
tweeted. She said, "Several months ago,
Charlie Kirk began to follow me and I
knew it meant his opinion on Israel was
starting to change." So you can see the
slow gradual evolution that's happening
but Israel and Benjamin that Satan does
not want people to remember that this is
what was actually happening behind the
scenes.
>> So the idea that Kirk was somehow
becoming a threat.
>> So now we're going to go to the actual
video of the propaganda and co and look
what they had to say just to break it
down inshallah for you guys in in a
palatable way. Let's go to the video.
>> So the idea that Kirk was somehow
becoming a threat to Israel was absurd.
But as many social media users have
pointed out, Kirk was in fact showing
signs of evolution. The same kind of
evolution that saw personalities like
Tucker Carlson, Candace Owens, and Megan
Kelly to name a few change their tune in
regards to America's relationship with
Israel. According to the Grey Zone, as
Israel's genocidal assault on the
besieged Gaza Strip drove an
unprecedented backlash within grassroots
right-wing circles, where only 24% of
younger Republicans now sympathize with
Israel over the Palestinians, Kirk began
to shift at times, he towed the Israeli
line, spreading disinformation about
babies beheaded by Hamas on October 7th
and denying the famine imposed on the
population of Gaza. Yet, he
simultaneously seated to his base,
wondering aloud if Jeffrey Epstein was
an Israeli intelligence asset,
questioning whether the Israeli
government allowed the October 7th
attacks to proceed in order to advance
long-term political goals, impering
narratives familiar to his most
viciferous critic on the right, streamer
Nick Fuentes. Back in July, Turning
Point USA held a student action summit
for young conservatives in Tampa,
Florida. As head of the organization,
Kirk would decide who to platform at
this event. In a decision that enraged
Zionists, Kirk decided to platform
Israel critics Tucker Carlson, Megan
Kelly, and comedian Dave Smith. At the
event, Tucker Carlson made several
incendiary comments, taunting the
Zionist billionaire Bill Aman. How did
Bill Aman get $9 million billion
dollars? Bill Aman a pretty impressive
guy. I know Bill Aman. No, Bill Aman's
like well-connected and super
aggressive. That's it.
>> And even suggested that Americans
serving in the IDF should lose their
citizenship
>> because you can only really pledge your
loyalty to one person or one country.
That's just a fact. Like anybody, by the
way, who serves in a foreign military
should lose a citizenship immediately.
There are a lot of Americans who served
in the IDF, they should lose their
citizenship. Can't fight for another
country and remain an American. Period.
>> Megan Kelly suggested that Jeffrey Epste
was an Israeli MSAD agent, but he was an
American, which leaves basically three
options. MI6, Saudi or MSAD? Which one
would you choose?
>> I guess given his connection to Gain
Maxwell.
So, what does that mean?
>> Well, I mean, it's possible that that's
the reason everything's getting buried,
that there is some treasure trove and
it's getting buried because
>> How many people here believe that? Raise
your hand. Okay, I'd say about half the
hands think that it's being buried
because of an Israeli thing.
>> And Dave Smith heavily criticized
Israel's genocidal actions in Gaza.
>> Cuz it's not a war, it's the destruction
of a captive people. Gaza has been
occupied since 1967 by the Israelis, and
they're now just slaughtering the people
there.
>> On social media, Zionist went into a
frenzy, denouncing Charlie Kirk as a
traitor. The Jewish Zionist Laura Loomer
tweeted, "After this weekend, I'd say he
has revealed himself as a political
opportunist." So you can see guys subh
you can see a pattern look what is going
on and this is what we have to remember
the evolution that happened of uh
Charlie Kirk was this this was the end
product this is what happened before he
got assassinated before he got killed
you can clearly see and this vile woman
whatever she's called okay after this
weekend I'd say he has revealed himself
as a political opportunist you can see
they want dead loyalty loyalty to you
cannot question them and we know the
capability of Israel and we know that
what they're capable of doing and we've
seen them even though they're still
losing the war without intelligence and
that whatever they have there's two
options number one they directly were
involved number two they were indirectly
involved how their intelligence is very
strong so they knew like they Charlie
Kirk said did they say stand down did
they say stand down the same thing when
it came to knowing that there is this
guy look this guy can be connected to
Mosad or no irrelevant they allowed it
to happen they could have stopped it but
they didn't So it's done and do it. So
they said stand down. No intention says
what? There is someone that wants to
take out Charlie Kirk. There's this guy
who hates him. No problem. Okay, let him
be. Stand down. Do you see? Subhan
Allah. The same thing they apply to the
guards. Yes. Okay. Stand down. Let them
do so we can commit out atrocities. And
Charlie Kirk also calls it out. He also
says that and he they did this. They did
the same thing with him. There's two
options from there. But let's carry on
in.
>> Lately, Kirk has decided to behave like
a charlatan. It really is shameful. And
honestly, I am just disgusted with the
constant flip-flopping on the right. In
the Times of Israel, a blogger called
Kirk out for promoting anti-semitism.
Quote, "Charlie, what are you doing? You
know the difference between goodfaith
critique and coded anti-semitism. When
people obsess over Apac while ignoring
Qatar, China, Saudi Arabia, the UN,
that's not objectivity. That's
targeting." Leadership also means
knowing when a conversation is no longer
a conversation. It's manipulation. It's
how the seeds of Jew scapegoating get
watered. Not by swastikas, but by just
asking questions. Finally, she warns
Charlie, don't abandon your post. You
stood for truth when it wasn't easy.
stand now with Israel with reason with
your own better judgment. And the Jewish
Zionists Mark Levvin and Ben Shapiro
also voiced their displeasure with Kirk
over who he platformed at the summit.
>> We, you and I had people who we thought
were conservatives sound a lot like the
Marxist Islamists who were attending
this event last week, don't they? They
find that conservative groups and
conservative organizations that have had
these weekend events and these seminars,
whether they're for young people or
think tanks or that sort of thing.
>> You cannot make this up, guys. You
cannot make this up. The more I'm
researching and looking into this, the
more it's like, wow.
Wow. blaming Islamists and this that
those days are over. It's not working.
Tommy Robinson and the far right did the
protest. It's not working. Burn flag.
It's not working. The world is waking
up. Even in his protest, a Zionist was
there a Yemen and they told him get out.
This is about British people. At least
the guy was consistent. Ironically, he's
at an event arranged by the biggest pro
Mosad Zidist Tom Robinson. I don't know
why an event and then telling a to get
out. Okay, there we go. So, not only
that, belongs sisters, if we read this
now, following the confab, Kirk was
bombarded with infuriated text messages
and phone calls from Netany's wealthy
allies in the US, including many who had
funded True USA. According to his
longtime friend, the Zionist donors
treated Kirk with outright contempt,
essentially ordering him to fall back
into line.
They're warning you. Look, look at this
guys. They are warning. They're saying,
"Listen, fall back into line." Publicly
and privately, brothers and sisters, he
is being pressured. He said that he felt
like his life was in danger.
You can't make this up. You cannot make
this up. Then he was being told what you
are not allowed to do and it was driving
him crazy. Kirk's friend called the cons
uh recalled the conser the conservative
youth leader was not only alienated by
the hostile nature of the interactions,
but frightened by the backlash.
frightened. Is this the clerk that loves
Israel? Nope. Gone of those days. Now,
Charlie Kirk rejected an offer earlier
this year from Israel's Prime Minister
Benjamin Net. Just imagine, guys, this
is their way of negotiating. What does
the mafia, the gang, Israel do? Listen,
critic publicly, privately. You don't
have to do this. We will fund you.
You're a good guy. Come back. No, no,
no. Not working. Okay, no problem. All
right. Netanyahu to arrange a uh so
Netanyahu to arrange a massive new
infusion of Zionist money into his
turning point. USA. Look, they want to
control everything. They want to own
everything. Everything belongs to them.
True USA organization, America's largest
conservative youth association,
according to a longtime friend of the
slain commentator speaking on the
condition of anonymity. Uh the source
told the grayzone that the late proTrump
influencer believed Netanyao was trying
to cow him into silence as he began to
publicly question Israel's overwhelming
influence in Washington and demanded
more space to criticize it. I wonder who
killed him. Islamist. Yeah. Islamist.
The left. Yeah. Okay. In the weeks
leading up to his September 10
assassination, Kirk had come to lo the
Israel leader regarding him as a bully.
Yeah. Yeah. And he's reading out a
letter in my last video saying, "Yeah,
he loved us." Yeah. Yeah. Partly reading
it. Yeah. The source said Kirk was
disgusted by what he witnessed inside
the Trump administration when Netanyahu
sought to personally dictate the
president's personal decisions and
weaponize Israel's assets like like a
billionaire donor. Okay? Like
billionaire donor Miriam Anderson to
keep the White House firmly under his
thumb. Like I said before, Trump is
owned by them. You voted for you voted
Trump in you vote Trump in you voted in
Netanyahu. He controlled the country.
And then um according to Kirk's friend
who uh who also employed access to
President Donald Trump and his inner
circle, Kirk strongly warned Trump uh
Trump last June against bombing Iran on
Israel's behalf. So did Iran Iran
benefit from Kirk's death? Nope. Charlie
was the only person who did that. They
said recalling how Trump barked at him
in response and angrily shut down the
conser conversation. The source believes
the incident confirmed in Kirk's mind
that the president of United States had
fallen under the control of a malign uh
foreign power and was leading his own
country into a series of destruction
conflicts.
By the following month, Kirk had come uh
to the target of sustained private
campaigns of intimidation uh and the
free floating fury by wealthy and
powerful allies of Netanyahu. You can't
make this up. You cannot make this up
guys. Okay? He was being intimidated.
>> Why is Megan like doing the bidding?
>> He was being intimidated. And here is
another clip that we haven't seen of
Megan and Charlie Kirk. Listen to
yourself.
>> Why is Megan like doing the bidding of
Hamas? I was like, what are you talking
about? Megan's the best. And I said, why
are you texting about Megan? This is
what they don't understand. You and I,
Megan, and Tucker is in the same
category and they've tried to go after
Tucker. The more you attack our moral
character, the actually the more we're
going to double down into direction
because screw you. I don't do it that
way. Okay? On some part of the
population,
>> you can scold them into silence. But if
I have any deviation of a purity test,
any deviation whatsoever, such as
hosting a focus group, right, Megan,
with a bunch of our students that went
viral, having Dave Smith or Tucker at my
event, it is all of a sudden, oh,
Charlie is a uh he's he's no longer with
us and all that. Wait a second. What do
you mean what does with us mean exactly?
Right. I'm an American. Okay. Like I I
represent this country. The more that
you guys privately and publicly call our
character into question, which is not
isolated, right? And again, it would be
one thing that just one text or two
text. It is dozens of texts.
>> Yes.
>> Then we start to say, "Hold the boat
here." And and to be fair, some of my
really good Jewish friends are like,
"That's not all of us. It's all but
these are leaders, too, though, right?
These are these are stakeholders, right?
I I'm I'm afraid because again, I want
civilization to win. I feel the
connection to Israel and I but at the
same time, simultaneously when the
hostile reaction is that now Megan and
Charlie are enemies, boy, I'll tell you
like you're you're you're you're going
to weaken and just basically deflate two
of your strongest advocates."
>> Do you hear that? If they're saying if
you are seeing us as your enemies, he
has issue with the private donors, the
Zionist billionaire private donors who
are friends of Benjamin Netanyahu,
Benjamin Netanya who's who's tried to
fund his organization turning point.
Do you are you guys are you are you guys
hearing this? Are you guys Israel is
written all over it. Somebody wrote the
mere possibility that Kirk and this is
so profound. The mere possibility that
Kirk could start start down the same
path
as Tucker and Candice is enough to send
shivers down the spine of any Zionist
with half a brain. Losing Kirk, even to
a moderate degree, would represent a
devastating blow to the Zionist power
based in America.
Ben do Dominic a co-founder of the
federalist federalist wrote if Charlie
Kirk remains the head of the true TP
TPUSA sorry I've been pronouncing that
wrong the right hand the right has
anti-semitic problem with problem that
will follow them into the coming
elections look at that check this out
yeah okay and as we know we talked about
Daniel Bloom okay the times of Israel
she wrote you know he's you know turning
point must continue to be safe haven for
aligned pro-American, pro-Israeli Jews
on campus for the future generations.
Look, they are petrified.
>> And brothers and sisters, we would end
on this note from that video from
propaganda and co for the Zionists. If
Kirk had continued, Donald Trump
credited Kirk NP USA for his election
victory, calling it your victory, not
mine. This is why the stakes were so
high for the Zionists. If Kirk had
continued drifting toward criticism of
Israel, it wouldn't just be another
commentator questioning Zionism. It
would mean the entire conservative youth
movement could begin shifting its views.
Unlike Tucker Carlson, Candace Owens, or
Nick Fuentes, who can be dismissed as
fringe and independent commentators,
Kirk and TPUSA had mainstream power.
They organized the grassroots. They had
access to the White House. That is
exactly why Netanyahu offered to
bankroll TPUSA to make sure Kirk never
turned that influence against Israel. As
the founder of this organization,
rejecting this funding essentially
denied Israel the ability to gain
leverage over Kirk's position as leader
of the organization. So, without access,
they couldn't threaten to remove him
from the position. And when gangsters
can't buy you or control you, well, they
kill you.
And that's what it is, guys. And these
guys are the most evil people on this
earth, designers. Within 24 hour of
Kirk's death, Shapiro announces that he
would be launching his own campus
speaking tour, vowing, we're going to
pick up the bloodstained microphone
where Charlie left it. The blood stained
microphone.
You're going to pick it up. And guess
what? You already have blood in your
hands. Yes. It's not that you grabbed
that mic that the blood came in your
hands. You are the ones. You guys, the
Zionists are the ones behind the
assassination.
You guys are behind it. Mossad is behind
it and it has got the blueprint every
single place. Brothers and sisters,
nothing else needs to say. Uh there is
another video I'm going to be doing
tomorrow about the individual, a man who
was there as a setup uh to divert
attention and his connection to Mossad
and 911 as a witness. Brothers and
sisters, things are getting crazy and
subhan Allah, the whole world is waking
up and it's the beginning and the end of
Israel. Alhamdulillah.